hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to would you rather are
you ready to compromise your integrity
for a bunch of personal satisfaction you
don't really get anything out of it you
just get a conundrum that makes your
gonna stay awake at night so let's get
into it would you rather have your elbow
joints facing the opposite direction or
have your knees facing backwards we'll
see if you had your elbows going the
other way you could always surprise
people behind you with a hug let's
follow you to close the line and your
elbows are going the wrong way you just
like ah my feet backwards and that's no
good if you had your knees facing
backwards now just eggs make sitting
hard you'd have to sit you'd always have
to do that cool lean where you turn the
chair around backwards and sit in it the
opposite direction but instead of your
legs being out to the side there sitting
normally in the chair which would be
weird
I like the reverse hug option that's
that's what I would go for that's what I
want I want a whole lot of that in my
life would you rather eat a container of
butter or drink a bottle of maple syrup
so you either get a whole bunch of fat
or you get a whole bunch of sugar now
given that I just got through keto I
actually have eaten the container of
butter there's video of me online where
I bite into a whole stick of butter if
you don't know what keto is it's that
diet where you eat a lot of fat it works
it sucks but hey I did it
I'll take the butter I'll choose the
road I've traveled versus the road
that'll probably kill me I'll choose the
road that I know will kill me versus the
road that will probably kill me I'll
take the butter oh you big babies
butters delicious I mean so is maple
syrup but hey I'll take the butter if
you were convicted of a crime would you
rather oh this is a conundrum go to jail
for life or have the death penalty
I mean it says convicted of a crime it
doesn't mean that I actually did it fine
it's like won't be the point in me dying
you know what I mean like would there be
a point in me dying for that crime would
I rather have the death penalty or go to
jail I'm pretty sure I would still
rather have the opportunity to go to
jail because it doesn't say there's no
room for parole because that that is an
option I could have parole and be under
house arrest or you know you know I
could still spend my life in jail trying
to do something like worthwhile like I
don't have to march down death row and
go right into that so I'll go to jail
thank you whoa that's actually
surprising that's actually surprising
people would rather more people would
rather have the death penalty than go to
jail what do you guys think about this
like I would love to know the reasoning
behind that because obviously being in
jail for life is a miserable existence
it's almost like like especially here in
America it's like what like is it even
worth it but just to like embrace death
like that and I mean it's like not like
I'm afraid of dying but there's still
more that I could do if I was in jail
for life like even if it affected a very
limited number of people it's not like I
could do my let's plays from jail but
you know no would you rather be Aquaman
or be the Human Torch
so it'd be always wet or always on fire
is that what you're asking me would I
rather always be slightly damp or always
just be a little too touchy in high
[ __ ] I don't know what a [ __ ] is out
of let's ignore that one the Human Torch
can fly so let's not forget about that
fact
Aquaman although in the new version of
it with that one guy who was Carl khal
drogo a big old man with big old beard
and big ol muscles and big trident I
mean I always thought that Aquaman was
cooler than everybody let on
dog food fish also he's king of the sea
so how about that I'm not king of the
land up here but he can I'm Ian Hertz
can't fly I'll be Aquaman I'll be
Aquaman that seems pretty badass get to
bang mermaids all day that sounds pretty
good oh I knew I'd be in the minority on
that one but I think I'll take that one
would you rather never listen to music
again or never play video games again
now I may have come across this before
but my life has changed a little bit
I've actually been finding myself
listening to music more and more I've
been listening to Ed Sheeran non-stop
but also I've been going into like I've
been listening to the sign of the times
about Harry Styles and I've also been
listening to do Alesha Cara and and a
little bit of James Arthur here and
there and I've been slowly meandering my
way through new musicians so I'm kind of
just getting into it oh also James
Rezanov McGee just pointed out some
videos games contain music oh yeah if I
had to play video games without music
like huh I guess I could play board
games that'd be pretty cool I wouldn't
be able to do Let's Plays again that's
for sure but hey I needed to remove the
copyrighted music anyway so I said to
lappa if I pick one I wouldn't be able
to do music oh would I rather never play
video games again that's a little
backwards okay would you rather never
play video games again I'll pick that
one okay all right I'm just gonna go
throw that out there cuz I think I
picked backwards but I also may have
picked the way I just picked because I
may have read the question wrong and I
have no idea would you rather be locked
in a New York City studio apartment with
400 pugs for a year you mean heaven or
be forced to round up all the pugs in
the US and put them on a boat bound for
North Korea I think I'll take the studio
apartment because number one that sounds
great because my bed would be pugs my
toy that would be bugs my kitchen would
be bugs I wouldn't be able to touch the
floor I'd have to have to get a bunch of
monkey bars up in the top of the ceiling
and like clamber over and have like a
strong hammock but also I have all God
the poop
Oh God the poop oh try to walk 400 bugs
oh I wouldn't be a lot I'd be locked in
there oh man how are they gonna eat I
know what I'm gonna eat no oh God it cuz
you're locked in there right eventually
you'd have to watch the wall tear each
other apart Oh God
if this heaven is running tumbling
around me oh my god that ax if you think
about that that's actually horrible I
mean if you just round them up and send
them off to North Korea hey maybe that's
gonna change their life and hey you may
not even be get through rounding them
all up before you die so that could take
forever you'd have to round up them all
that means you have to convince people
to give up their pugs and that ain't
gonna happen so you'd be conversing with
family I'd been stuck in legal paperwork
for years that's better than drowning
and pug vomit and poop and pee and a
corpses of pugs I'll take that one now
that I think about it I'll take that one
Oh okay would you rather attempt to
survive a computer uprising as in
Terminator or attempt to survive an
zombie outbreak Dawn of the Dead okay so
there's a certainty of death in both of
these in the computer uprising and
terminator they nuked about 90% of the
population a lot of people died right
away but in a zombie apocalypse a lot of
people died right away and I'd probably
be one of them either way here it's only
says attempt to survive because I'm
pretty sure that I would not do very
well and with the computer uprising hey
at least the Earth's in good hands with
computers after we're all gone if a
zombie outbreak happens hey nothing gets
done so I'll take dying in the computer
uprising versus dying in the zombie
outbreak because that seems horrible I
mean this is horrible but at least
you're gonna die quick with a laser to
the face or a nuke to the ass I'll take
that one I'll take that one everyone's
like oh walking dead nod you'd be fought
or - maybe like 5% of you you you'd be
survivors or what none maybe you're
immune I don't know
but majority of you me included we're
gonna be zombie food would you rather
discover the Loch Ness monster or
discover Sasquatch okay here's where I
have a problem with this the Loch Ness
monster if you're stuck discovering the
Loch Ness monster that means you're in
the middle of that lake when you
discover it because I have a funky
feeling that you're not gonna be fishing
on the shore and all sudden old Nessie
pops his head out of the ocean and be
like or the sea or the lake or the Loch
and be all like hey what you doing 350
joke dude I think I think the only way
you're gonna discover Loch Ness is when
you're in a little dinky rowboat out in
the middle of the sea loch and you like
top-down view you just see huge jaws
just coming up under your boat from
underwater but you don't notice it oh
you're like oh so serene now that
there's no Loch Ness and then as its JA
start to close on your boat you're like
I discovered you dead and you're gone
that's how that works
if you discover the Sasquatch hey maybe
you can be buddies I've seen the
commercials big the Sasquatch yeah Oh
fine if you could choose an age to stay
forever would you rather be 21 or be 10
why would you choose to be 10 let me
think of a reason why you would choose
to be 10 okay what do you have at 10
you're not a teenager yet you haven't
gone through puberty you got your
childlike innocence people tend to like
I don't know no one likes you actually
you're just annoying at 10 you're kind
of annoying you gotten out of the cute
kid phase but you're not quite in the
teen phase you're just a little kind of
ratty brat but if you're 21
that seems like great who wouldn't I
can't take them do you guys have a
single reason why you would want to be
10 forever
I would I would want to be this seems
obvious
why am I thinking so hard about this the
21 is obvious you're almost at your peak
you're almost fully grown like you're in
the peak of your youth you're you're
you're officially an adult you get to do
out anything you want if you're ten
you're just a kid it's not like your
brain hasn't developed fully yet so you
got that childlike innocence that stupid
[ __ ] childlike innocence 21:8 work
whatever you want to do ask 21 good
would you rather be hunted by people or
hunt people so this is like the the the
the per being hunted by people you may
have the moral high ground but you also
probably got a bullet to the heart
if you haunt people you got the moral
low ground but also probably you're
gonna get a bullet to the heart I don't
like either of these whatever world were
in when this has to happen it's it's
quite a conundrum here so I'm just gonna
go out and hunt me I just hunt me just
on me I'll be fair game I'll make it
interesting for you I'll do a dance
before you shoot if that's what I'll do
I'll make I'll make it good for you Oh
would you rather have a flying car or
have a one terabyte per second internet
connection I've recently just got
gigabit internet and it's amazing I
cannot imagine what terabyte internet
would unlock for me but a flying car I'm
assuming you're the only one that has it
because that doesn't exist in the world
here so then you could use that to
patent it you could reverse engineer and
like secure a future for yourself and
then buy a one terabyte Internet
connection but also with the one
terabyte entered per second internet
connection you could start your own
hosting company you can do unlimited
number of things with I'm assuming you
don't have to pay for this thing maybe
you do I don't know I'm assuming it
comes for free like you just
happenstance upon it all right I'm gonna
leave this one to you I'm gonna leave
this one to you there's pluses and
minuses here because the the benefit of
one terabyte internet connection is on
because it's terabit sorry it's one
terabit per second which is still an
ungodly amount that's a thousand
gigabits per second that's a thousand of
these lines of Internet you could
transfer I could transfer my entire
computer in eight seconds or I'll leave
this one to you which one would you guys
rather have a flying car or one terabyte
per second internet connection both are
good you could get the flying car and
panned it or you could just do whatever
you want you could download the entire
internet on a one terabit per second
which one would you guys rather - so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below as always I will see you
in the next video
[Music]